- Good morning, Believe Nation.
My name is Evan Carmichael.
My one word is believe, and
I believe that entrepreneurs
will solve all of the
worlds major problems.
So to help you on your journey,
today's message is outdo yourself.
Over to you, Simon Sinek.
(rooster crows)
♫ I wake up every mornin'
♫ Espresso keep me goin'
- I spoke at an education
summit for Microsoft.
I also spoke at an
education summit for Apple.
At the education summit for Microsoft,
I would say that 70% of the executives
spent about 70% of their presentations
talking about how to beat Apple.
At the Apple education summit,
100% of the executives spent
100% of their presentations
talking about how to help teachers teach,
and how to help students learn.
One is playing this way,
and one is playing that way.
One is playing finite,
and the other one is infinite.
Guess which one gets frustrated.
(audience laughs)
So at the end of my talk at Microsoft,
they gave me a gift.
They gave me the new
Zune when it was a thing.
(audience laughs)
And let me tell you, this
thing was spectacular.
It was the most elegant piece
of technology I'd ever used.
The user interface was incredible.
The design was spectacular.
I absolutely loved it.
It was easy to use, and it was bright,
and gorgeous and fanta,
it didn't work on iTunes,
which is a different problem.
So I couldn't use it,
but it was amazing.
(audience laughs)
And elegant, my God, it was elegant.
So I'm sitting in the
back of a taxi with a
very senior Apple executive,
sort of employee number 12 kind of guy,
and you know, I like to stir pots,
so I turned to him, I said,
"You know...
Microsoft gave me their new Zune,
and it is so much better
than your iPod touch."
And he turned to me, and
he said, "I have no doubt."
Conversation over.
(audience laughs)
Because the infinite player understands,
sometimes you're ahead, and
sometimes you're behind.
Sometimes your product is
better and sometimes it's worse.
The goal isn't to be the best every day.
The goal isn't to outdo
your competition every day.
That's a finite construction.
If I had said to Microsoft,
"I've got the new iPod touch
and it's so much better
than your Zune", they would have said,
"Can we see it, what does it do?"
React, react, react, react.
Finite players play to beat
the people around them.
Infinite players play to
be better than themselves.
To wake up every single day and say,
how can we make our
company a better version
of itself today than it was yesterday?
How can we create a product
this week that's better
than the product we created last week?
We also have to play the infinite game.
It's not about being ranked number one.
It's not about having more followers
on Twitter than your friends.
It's not about outdoing anyone.
It's about how to outdo yourself.
It's not about selling more books,
or getting more TED
views than somebody else.
It's about how to make sure that the work
that you're producing is better than
the work you produced before.
You are your competition.
And that is what ensures you
stay in the game the longest,
and that is what ensures you find joy.
Because the joy comes,
not from comparison,
but from advancement.
- So I think having enemies
is actually a good thing.
I think enemies can push you to be better,
to do more, to go stronger.
It doesn't mean you have to copy them,
but I think they push you to
be a better version of you.
Tupac was better because of Biggie.
The Yankees are better
because of the Red Sox.
Apple is better because Microsoft exists.
I'm better because of people like
Gary Vaynerchuk and Grant
Cardone, and all these other guys
who are making YouTube videos as well.
It doesn't mean that we copy them, right?
The way the way that Gary wins is through
his speeches and through his vlogs,
and daily people following him around.
If I was just copying him and saying,
well this is the way to win,
I need to do exactly that,
then I'm going to lose.
If you look at your competition and say,
I'm just going to be a
copycat, that's when you lose.
Because you can't out-them them, right?
I can't out-Gary Gary, and
Gary can't out-Evan Evan.
It's just not possible, right?
So if you look at your
competition just saying
I'm a copycat, you've lost already.
But to look at them and
see they're growing,
they're gaining, you know,
they're getting more market share,
they're getting more
customers, they're getting
more subscribers, that
can push you to do better.
Sprinters do better when they have
people behind them who are also good.
If you're constantly
the best in your field
and you have no
competition, then it's easy
to get complacent, it's easy to get lazy,
it's easy to relax.
And so, I think having
enemy is a good thing,
but I definitely agree
with you need to try
to outdo yourself every single day.
I look at myself as my
competition, I look at my videos
from last week and say,
how do I do better,
how do I get better?
Yes, I want to aspire
to be like a Les Brown,
or a Tony Robbins and learn from them,
and their skills, and their abilities,
and not be them, but learn from them
to be a better version of
me, and I want to be better
than I was last week, and the week before,
and the week before, and the week before.
And you may not always see a
difference from week to week.
But you can definitely see
a difference with more time.
There's been a lot of people
come back to my videos from
five, six years ago, and say,
"Wow so much has changed!"
You know, I'm still the
same guy, I still have
the same points of view,
but my abilities have grown
because I've practiced.
We've done 5,000 videos, right?
You got to get good at something
if you've done it 5,000 times.
Even if you're practicing
really inefficiently,
you better get good at anything
if you're trying it 5,000 times.
And so, I think it's really important that
you can look up to other people,
you can look up to your
rivals potentially,
and say these people are
pushing me to do better,
to be more myself, to work
harder, to grind it out more,
to hustle more, and...
I'm not going to use
external people as my
barometer of success.
Because if I'm only looking at Les Brown,
I say, well, maybe I'll
never get to Les Brown level.
Don't use that to beat you
down, use it as a kick forward.
And, I want to compare myself
to how I was last week.
'Cause if you're only comparing yourself
when you are at your start,
to somebody else's middle
or somebody else's end,
it's not a fair fight.
And so you can use that as
inspiration, but tactically,
and practically, on a day
to day, week to week basis,
competing and beating
and outdoing yourself
is super important.
So I don't think it's one or the other.
I think you take the
best of both to help you
become the best version of yourself.
So the question today is, I'm curious,
what have you done to
recently outdo yourself?
If you're looking back
a week, a month, a year,
what have you gotten really good at
that you weren't so good at before?
Have a little bit of a brag,
show some love for yourself,
have a little bravado.
It's okay this time, I
want to see it come out.
Leave it down in the comments
below, really curious
to see what you have to say.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Jonathan Balgame.
Jonathan, thank you so much
for picking up a copy of
my book, Your One Word, and
taking a picture with it
and posting it on Twitter,
it was awesome to see,
and I'm really thankful for your support,
and I'm glad that you enjoyed my book.
So thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is, much love,
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of entspresso.
♫ I wake up every mornin'
♫ Espresso keep me goin'
(typewriter clacking)
- How many times have you
ever heard the phrase,
you are perfect, just as you are?
Have you heard that a lot, man?
You know what, you are
perfect just as you are,
you are so perfect just as you are.
Well you know what, you are not.
You are not perfect just as you are.
You are perfect, but you're not complete.
This is the thing, and this
is what I mean by that.
A lot of people are going to
go, oh what do you mean, I'm,
what are you trying to
say, I got to change?
I got to change into somebody else?
Yes, yes.
You need to change.
Everybody, everybody out
there needs to change.
We are designed for change.
Nothing in this world stays the same.
You are either getting better,
or you are getting worse.
Let me describe something to you.
When I say you are perfect,
but you are not complete,
let's say this building I'm in.
If I looked at the
blueprints for this building.
The blueprints for this building
before it was built were perfect.
Everything was in its right
place, everything was great.
But could I walk in it?
Could I do anything?
Did I have a building?
No, why?
It wasn't complete.
When they framed up this
building and put wood, and metal,
and all this stuff, but
they didn't do the floor,
didn't do the electrical, was it perfect?
Yes, it was perfect.
But it wasn't complete.
You are like this building.
You are perfect in every way,
but you're just not done.
You're not done.
And you know what?
Anybody's trying to tell
you, don't try to change me.
Now, no one should try to change you,
but you have to change yourself.
You owe it to everyone to change yourself
into a better person.
Into a better human being.
That's what you have to do.
You are perfect.
But you're just not complete.
So, when you look at yourself,
look at yourself as that building.
And it's framed up, and everything
is in it's right place,
but you're just not done.
I want to tell you that.
So anybody who's trying to tell you that,
I'm perfect just the way I am
is not trying to change.
And guess what?
You're not.
And it's not working.
You're a half done building.
Who wants to live in a
building with no roof?
Nobody.
And I'm just trying to
break it down to you,
that you hear these catchphrases.
You hear this stuff all the time.
And everybody just takes it and says,
oh yeah, I'm perfect just the way I am,
and you don't change.
And your life doesn't change,
and nothing gets better for you,
and you wonder what's happening.
And everything is crumbling around you.
Hey, I'm guilty.
Terry Crews is guilty.
Then I realize, wait a minute.
Wait a minute.
I'm not perfect just the way I am.
I have to be perfected.
I am perfect, but I am not complete.
- At the end of the day, this
is called the music business.
You've got to continue always find ways
to better your business.
It's kind of like Apple.
You know, if he stayed
on a laptop, then what would he be?
No.
What did Steve Jobs and the
whole team come up with?
iTouch, iPad, iPod, now it's iCloud.
It's always finding ways to get better,
and that's the way I
looked at it through music.
I said well, now I can
just go from rapping
to everybody in the
neighborhood, to the whole world,
and it worked.
And now everybody's doing it.
Now I got to figure out the next move.
Now I got to figure
out my next iSomething.
(laughs)
- I don't write down
goals, and go get 'em.
I know a lot of people do
that, but I just kind of
try to outdo myself.
Outdo my last outdo.
And although this is a
competition, in every sport,
and I look at this industry has a sport,
because it's numbers and it's
money, and it's achievements,
and it's championships, and et
cetera, et cetera, you know.
I'm only really in
competition with myself.
You know, although it is,
you know, a fun competition
to look over and see
what your homie doing,
and see, you know what I mean?
For me it's all about bettering me,
bettering the music I make,
bettering my fan experience,
bettering my business,
bettering myself as a man.
The truth is, there's a lot I want
to accomplish in the music industry.
There's a lot I want to
accomplish as a businessman.
I haven't done a lot of those things yet,
although I have done a
lot, I feel like I'm just
getting my feet wet and the
ceiling is very high for me.